bon mes chéris vous êtes l'étroit dans
une même chambre
donc on a voulu vous faire un petit
cadeau ce soir je vous le dis on a voulu
vous offrir trois magnifiques chambres
pour vos enfants une chambre pour chacun
voilà donc on va refaire les trois
chambres donc vous auriez cette chambre
là cette chambre la nouvelle approche et
cette chambre là vous allez avoir chacun
vos chambres les enfants donc ma chérie
ça y est il ya plus de problème et anne
va être content céline c'est bon alors
arrêtez de pleurer sinon tout le monde
va pleurer non mais c'est vrai mais bon
le problème qu'il ya c'est que est-ce
que vous avez la place de mettre les
trois chambres dans la maison venait
fournis par l'abonné par la ceni est-ce
que vous avez la place de mettre les
trois chambres dans la main c'est son
problème
c'est ça le problème c'est vrai que
parce que je me dis si on met les trois
chambres vous vivez dans un coma de
carrie 68 m² en faudrait qu'on fasse des
ouais ça va être quoi va être compliqué
ce soir c'est noël et ce soir j'ai envie
de vous offrir un peu plus que les trois
chambres un appart regarder dans l'écran
céline ce soir est ce qu'on peut faire
tomber la bâche s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]